[Music]
we love bernard the artists we're about
to check out imagine to their favorite -
my little pony characters as babies
young fillies and colts let's explore
the art and the backstory of these
characters that you can't guess what
Rainbow Dash was like at a baby stick
around until the end to find out if this
is your first time at the things don't
forget to hit that subscribe button and
give this video a big thumbs up now
let's jump right into my little pony
characters growing up Granny Smith
Granny Smith is an extremely important
resident of Ponyville she's the eldest
member of the well respected Apple
family that earns her a lot of respects
from the other ponies she wasn't always
the white-haired wrinkled grandma we
know and love she was pretty much the
cutest baby ever
check her out all swaddled up artist I
implode imagines granny when she was
just a tiny little pony even Granny
Smith was a filly once artist Abner has
imagined her in her youth being an elder
isn't the only thing that earns her
respect on family appreciation day
Granny Smith accompanies Apple Bloom to
school she's offering their presentation
to Apple Bloom's class about the Apple
family history the other little ponies
listened with excitement as she
describes just how much she's done for
Ponyville when granny was just a little
filly Ponyville hadn't been founded yet
granny wondered into the everfree forest
to find food for her family
granny herself actually discovered the
magical lap apples the jam the Apple
family made from them was so delicious
that ponies came from all over Equestria
to taste it this led to Ponyville being
founded and growing into the city it is
today granny may have had the most
important childhood of any character on
the show not too many characters can say
they've lived in Ponyville since the
beginning big Macintosh
big Macintosh is the big brother of
Applejack
watch divert ports hurt goodbye subbu he
was also an adorable baby beaver Nader
gives us a peek at the pony when he was
tiny
his wild mop of hair is too cute takua
seven seven zero shows us a young wild
colt Big Mac Big Brother's usually have
a lot of responsibility not only is he a
big brother but he also grew up on a
farm he was in charge of taking care of
his baby sister and all of his farm
chores his childhood was full of hard
work growing up he had to look out for
Applejack and their little sister Apple
Bloom the Apple siblings live with their
grandmother on the family farm an older
Guardian often needs a lot of health and
that usually falls to the oldest he
doesn't speak very often and when he
does his words are few that might be
because he's been so busy since he was a
little Colt that he never got into the
habit of speaking much his oldest sister
and Granny both have a tendency to gab
maybe he just never got a word in
edgewise and has always kept quiet being
a big strong pony he probably had a ton
of chores on the farm too that would
explain why she's so skilled in every
part of his operation today he's
obviously very close to his sisters his
bond with them is stronger than most
siblings we think it might be because he
spent so much time raising them
Scootaloo Scootaloo is one of the
youngest ponies on a show to get so much
screen time thanks to the artist Zig
rock 0:01
we get to see every stage of her
development not just when she was
introduced on the show check out this
cutie sugar cup 91 draws her as a
slightly older filly to her love of
Rainbow Dash leads to her parents
finding out that she's a Wonderbolt
that's a big plot point for such a
little pony her origin story is shrouded
in mystery her parents never make an
appearance on the show
they're never even mentioned in the
chapter book Ponyville mysteries riddle
of the rusty horseshoe we find out that
Scootaloo doesn't even live with them
she lives with her aunt holiday and her
auntie lofty this has raised some
eyebrows among fans
the book says her parents are away most
of the
time where are they away at what could
be more important than raising their
daughter My Little Pony Friendship is
Magic creator Lauren Faust has given her
own conflicting information in one
interview she dropped a shocking bomb
Scootaloo doesn't have any parents how
can that be true where did she come from
if she doesn't have a family
later Faust said but she did have
parents but they had demanding jobs and
were away constantly no matter which
storyline is true she definitely has one
of the most mysterious childhoods of any
of the ponies spike unlike most of the
other characters on the show we've seen
most of Spike's childhood including his
birth that didn't stop artists the last
gherkin from creating one of the cutest
images of baby spike ever look at those
big eyes and check him out in this hat
bye cutie marks when Twilight Sparkle
was just a filly she was accepted into
Princess Celestia's school for gifted
unicorns after she was accepted she had
to pass an entrance exam the exam was
pretty straightforward Twilight Sparkle
had to hatch a dragon egg with magic at
first she struggled to produce any magic
effect at all Rainbow Dash's Sonic
Rainboom changed to that it startled
Twilight Sparkle's so much that all of
her latent magic was released at once
not only did she had spike but she made
him the size of an adult dragon
obviously that was fixed because spike
is now a normal size for a dragon his
age Twilight Sparkle is really the only
mother he's ever known he was so curious
about his heritage that he joined the
dragon migration to learn more about his
people yes dragon the only way I'm gonna
do that is to join the dragon migration
the other dragons he met weren't
entirely welcoming they teased him for
being small and spending time with
ponies he decided that being true to
himself is what matters most and went
back to Twilight Sparkle a more
confident assistant it's pretty cool
watching him grow up before our very
eyes Fluttershy poor little Fluttershy
some ponies are just born talented and
successful others struggle and have to
work hard Fluttershy was one of the
ponies who struggled I feel good I feel
ready to attack the day
in real session she grew up in
Cloudsdale all the pegasi there have to
fly as part of their everyday lives
they're often judged on their flying
skills Rainbow Dash is popular because
she's one of the fastest little
Fluttershy wasn't so lucky
she was a weak flier from the beginning
and struggled to master even the basics
the same ponies that used to pick on
Rainbow Dash they were so mean and
called her awful names like Fluttershy
how rude can you get at least she was a
beautiful baby brony boy made this pick
up baby Fluttershy so we can all COO
over her look how little and innocent
she is free dark imagines her as a filly
in this adorable pic it's hard not to
feel bad for her she's a sweet pony she
shows so much love and compassion for
animals she's been known to adopt and
rehabilitate creatures in the forest
near her cottage her soft-spoken and shy
nature make her an easy target for
bullies as an adult Fluttershy became an
average skill flier she still has some
problems from time to time when she's
scared she can become incapable of
flight and that's a huge problem for a
pony that's afraid of so much she has a
lot of friends who love and respect her
bullying isn't a problem for her anymore
but she's still that shy nervous pony
Applejack little Applejack is so
precious artists got a fury created this
sweet happy image of the baby pony in
her hats Ellis arts imagines her as a
filly before her hair was caned into a
pony tail as cute as she is Applejack's
childhood has a painful secret the Apple
family is huge and they all love each
other very much there do seem to be two
people conspicuously missing Apple Jacks
parents never make a current appearance
on the show they're barely even
mentioned the show's creator lauren
faust knows where they are but she says
the show will likely never allow it to
be mentioned
sadly Applejack's parents have passed
away in the episode Apple family reunion
two shooting stars appeared over the
family farm storyboard artist Sabrina
Albert Getty confirmed that those stars
were meant to represent Apple Jacks
parents we get a single glimpse of them
in a flashback in the memory
see the love that Applejack's parents
shared apples dad was bright mac and her
mom was pear butter there was a
long-standing feud between the apple and
pear families making their love
forbidden we don't know how their Romeo
and Juliet love story ended but we know
they were together at some point we're
glad they got to have their sweet
daughter but we can't help but wonder
what happened to them
Pinkie Pie Pinkie Pie definitely had one
of the most strict too conservative
childhoods of all the ponies some bands
have even called her upbringing abusive
her family is so conservative that even
their coats and Mane's are dull earthy
colors that doesn't stop kinky from
being one of the cutest babies we've
ever seen deviantART user jrk zero eight
zero zero four created this image of
baby pinky check out how cozy she looks
in her bed
pinky beaker imagines a filly pinky with
the fun personality we all know and love
pinky grew up on a rock farm where there
was no talking or smiling her family is
extremely patriarchal what dad says goes
after the Sonic Rainboom Pinkie Pie
decides it's high time they start having
fun she organizes a party and surprises
her family you'd expect a bunch of
hard-working ponies to be excited about
the chance to have some fun the pie
family actually seemed more scared than
excited they stood around in silence
seeming to tremble and tau pinkies dad
showed up everyone stared at him anxious
to see his reaction after he approved of
the party only then did everyone else
relax and had some fun some fans think
that that behavior was a clear sign that
the family was being ruled with an iron
fist
where they simply hard-working and
conservative people or did their parents
take it too far
rarity baby rarity look how adorable
rarity was it's a newborn can you even
handle it
artist brony boy share this gem with the
world and now we can all see her
cuteness she's even precious as a filly
rarity 6195 created this super cute
image of rarity in formalwear rarities
childhood is a bit of a mystery
accentuate my mane it makes for a
captivating color story when you present
them to whomever they're intended we
know who her parents are and of course
her baby's sister Sweetie Belle it takes
a little bit of detective work to get a
clear picture of what things were like
for the sisters growing up let's start
by taking a look at her parents her dad
is Hondo flanks he's a pretty basic
unicorn he likes sports and enjoys
fishing nothing too exciting there
her mom is cookie crumbles she loves her
kids and likes to cook both parents seem
to love the sisters but it kind of seems
like they have a favorite in a lot of
families the youngest child gets the
most attention it kind of makes sense
because younger kids need more help and
Rarity's family we see a lot of
attention paid to Sweetie Belle her mom
gives her cooking lessons which is so
cute both parents are seen taking her to
the fair what did we already get from
her parents the responsibility of
babysitting her little sister what I
went on vacation sure it's cool that
they trust her so much doesn't Verity
get to have any fun with her folks
Twilight Sparkle
artists mighty 3:55 has imagined what
twilight sparkle looks like as a baby
this precious Pony is so cute we can't
resist black m3s H made a series of the
ponies as young fillies - I was
definitely a cute kid Twilight Sparkle
is a lucky pony she's not only really
talented but she has a family that backs
her up no matter what because room for
the one thing I want to do her parents
haven't been in a ton of episodes but we
do meet them a few times
her dad is nightlight and her mom is
twilight velvet they support Twilight
and everything she does when she has a
flashback to one of her happiest moments
her parents are right by her side in the
fun memory her parents show her
acceptance letter to Princess Celestia's
school for gifted unicorns she's
thrilled to get into the prestigious
school and her parents are so proud they
even accompanied her to her entrance
exam at the exam Twilight Sparkle is
doing pretty well until a sudden
distraction throws her off while she's
concentrating she's interrupted by a
Sonic Rainboom that appears many people
thought of the Sonic Rainboom as a myth
before that moment she had no idea that
with Rainbow Dash creating the colorful
spectacle it threw off her magic games
so bad that she accidentally turned her
parents into a cactus in an agave plant
don't worry princess celestia calmed her
down and her parents went right back to
normal even with that slip-up princess
celestia was still really impressed with
Twilight she even invited her to become
a personal student her parents were
right there to encourage her and cheer
her on
it seems like Twilight Sparkle had a
really loving family and a great
childhood Rainbow Dash
have you ever wondered what Rainbow Dash
is childhood was like everyone loves
this spunky pony she's probably one of
the most popular ponies on the show a
few episodes have given us a lot of info
about her childhood artist kaha has even
given us a peek of what she looks like
as a baby
check out this adorable art of the pony
when she was super young how cute is
this black m3s H gives us a look at
Rainbow Dash as a spunky kid that
rumbled mane is precious we've also
gotten to know her parents her dad is Bo
hot who he kind of looks like rainbow
blaze and lots of people think they're
related
her mom is named windy whistles both of
her parents love her a ton they're
really proud of their little girl but
they don't always show it in the best
way when she was a kid her parents came
to every competition she participated in
having your parents in the stands to
cheer you on may sound awesome we all
liked it when our families support us
Rainbow Dash didn't get support though
she got loud screaming and giant glitter
signs that was so humiliating for the
young pony the other kids made fun of
her for her loud and rowdy family that's
not the only reason Rainbow Dash grew up
under a lot of pressure
her parents set her up to feel like she
needed to be the best of everything she
did her entire childhood scrapbook is
full of photos of her parents grating
her every move from the start she knew
she was expected to be the best overall
it seems like her parents loved her so
much that her childhood must have been
pretty nice even if she did feel
pressured to be the best we hope you
like seeing these ponies as little Colts
and fillies we'll see you next time
[Music]